new bombshells about the sex and the
city reboot hello
it's me
sarah jessica parker just got super real
about a kim catrell return doubling down
on what she told et at the end just like
that premiere is the door open for a
potential return no i mean that wasn't
something that we ever talked about but
after the samantha texts in the finale
teasing a visit sjp was asked if she
would ever be okay with kim making an
appearance down the road quote i don't
think i would because i think there's
just too much public history of feelings
on her part that she shared we didn't go
to kim for this you know
and remember this brunch scene in
episode one these are my very best
friends in the new hbo max doc about the
series which is streaming now show
runner michael patrick king says he
didn't want to make it seem like nicole
ari parker's character was replacing
samantha i didn't want to tell the
audience
one two three
fourth
she's the new samantha all right i'm
gonna be late so i had carrie and
miranda get up and leave i should go too
and she sits at the table oh and there's
more drama can i take you out to dinner
just you and me actor john corbett who
played aiden but never appeared in the
reboot is under fire last year he told
page six i'm going to do the show i
think i might be in quite a few episodes
well one of the show's writers just
revealed that was never in the works and
quote john corbett should be writing
personal apology notes
but our favorite part of the doc this
tour of sjp's fashion storage space she
has the whole staten island
outfit i lost my chew
i lost my chew
what i wouldn't give for just a day
walking through that archive yes it's
all catalog
look at the first one
from the opening credits tutu to this
cream silk dior
at one time this was the most expensive
dress we ever bought her it was in the
window at dior when we have like
probably i would say how much of sex in
the city
80
it's a picture of time spent with a lot
of really talented designers